in some cases choosing game at the month
is difficult because the month is light
on standouts and heavy on games that are
good or even great but not necessarily
masterful in the case of March of 2015
the choice has been difficult for a very
different reason because several games
are so clearly worthy of great praise we
didn't just award one or two games with
nines
in March rewarded four of them what a
wonderful month March turned out to be
four games and not just because there
was so many quality experiences but
because they were so different from each
other it's a testament to the variety we
so often overlooked in modern game
design that truly is something for
everyone if you enjoy testing your
reflexes with hyper-violent shooting for
instance that was hotline miami - a
top-down action game with the slick ad
style and a white-hot soundtrack if you
like your action with a dose of attitude
and an otherworldly ambiance there was
DMC Devil May Cry a current generation
rate release of a rapturous last
generation ROM if you wanted laid-back
strategy cities skylines argued for your
time by being everything you wanted the
newest SimCity to be that never was and
by being a modest paradise opening
itself up to all manner of community
developed modifications cooperative
hurting expansive role-playing and
Metroid style challenges March of 2015
had what you needed Orion the blind
forest stood apart even in a month
crowded with wonderful gems this
gorgeous platformer married fluidity of
movement with the touching story of
friendship using its beauty not as a
crutch but as a compliment telling you
that we didn't award it much as top
honor is almost as heartbreaking as are
his own opening sequence however
blood-borne power has proven inescapable
in this contest from software's newest
monument to challenging action
our matched world-building may be
similar to the developers own sold
series but it pops out its own niche
with its overt religious themes it's
focused on mobility and an array of
hideous bosses that require focus
determination and a bit of tense
grinding to overcome in a month of
delights that feeling when you finally
do overcome your most recent challenge
is what boosts blood-borne to the top of
the heat lots of games are fun
very few provides this kind of
exhilaration congratulations blood-borne
for hammering our souls to a bloody pulp
and all but pulling the award for game
of the month from our Wizards floors
it's an honor to be vanquished by a game
so mighty